foreign
welcome back to the technical guide for
startups a video series where we help
startups to start build and grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud hello everyone I am
bhavika and I'm anirudh and we are both
customer engineers at Google Cloud
in our previous video we covered how to
optimize for sustainability
today we will be talking about Cloud
spanner Google Cloud's fully managed
horizontally scalable and strongly
consistent relational database
today we start off by discussing common
challenges for
Fitness spanner and how it helps to
overcome those challenges next we'll
understand when Cloud spanner is the
right fit
after that we talk about pricing model
and how to migrate your existing
databases to Cloud spanner towards the
end we take a quick tour to Cloud
spanner console and wrap up with a
customer success story
let's start by identifying the
challenges we face with traditional
databases
most databases have common
characteristics which make them
unsuitable for scaling elastically in
Cloud native environment
firstly most TVs are only vertically
scalable you can add more CPU memory and
disk to a database instance but can not
easily add more instances this naturally
requires downtime for scaling your
database and imposes a practical limit
you cannot scale a single VM infinitely
when this limit is inevitably reached
companies normally resort to sharding
which means segregating the data on some
criteria and storing each segment on a
different database instance while in
theory this enables horizontal scaling
but Shady databases are hard to manage
and hard to keep consistent leading to
additional costs and operational efforts
secondly maintaining databases is
traditionally a high effort task
requiring dedicated team of
Administrators to ensure business
continuity
these teams need to handle Hardware
breakdowns OS and software updates and
replacement of end-of-life resources all
while ensuring minimal disruption
schema changes May incur downtime as
well additionally it is common practice
to tweak database parameters and
administrators need to rebuild indices
periodically to ensure Optimal
Performance of these databases thirdly
keeping replicas in sync is a
non-trivial task and there will always
be a finite replication delay in
asynchronous replication
lastly it becomes increasingly difficult
to have strong consistency across all
replicas
let's now talk about the cost of such
systems most of it is hidden as you can
see this Iceberg image the top three
issues are manageability upgradability
and downtime
let's say your database server can
handle 10 000 layers then you have to
manage 100 servers for each million
players which makes it hard to manage
next when the players are from all over
the world playing at any time of the day
the database has to function 24x7 in
this case it's impossible to find a
maintenance window that suits everyone
making upgradability a major challenge
in this case
and lastly most traditional relational
databases offer High availability using
a failover mechanism this means if the
DB server fails it will recover but it
generates downtime
we've got you covered with Cloud spanner
Google Cloud's fully managed
horizontally scalable and globally
consistent relational database
it provides industry-leading external
consistency without compromising on
scalability or availability
Cloud spanner combines relational
semantics with horizontal scale
you get relational semantics with
schemas enforce data types strong
consistency and asset transactions
across rows and SQL queries using Google
standard SQL as well as the postgresql
dialect and you get all this with
horizontal scaling so you can scale to
large database sizes
this is all fully managed for you with
either four nines or five lines of
availability depending on whether you're
running the regional or the
multi-regional configuration
Cloud spanner scales easily and quickly
as an online operation with just a few
clicks or an API call
and all of this comes with The Familiar
postgres SQL interface
as we discussed previously
most traditional relational databases
have limitations associated with
replication availability and scalability
non-relational or no SQL databases
address these limitations in many
respects but they have their own
challenges such as no support or partial
support for SQL
eventual consistency at best
and limited data types and schemas
forcing significant re-architecting and
placing limitations on analytic
capabilities
however with Cloud spanner you get full
SQL support including standard tables
and columns that you'd see in any other
relational database
data is automatically sharded and
re-sharded based on load and data size
and you get acid transactions across
partitions
in addition to all the traditional
benefits of a SQL database
Cloud spanner provides strongly
consistent transactions continuous
availability schema changes without
downtime fully automatic data
replication and server redundancy but
unlike many other relational databases
Cloud spanner scales horizontally from
one to thousands of servers
let me illustrate with an example how
Cloud spanner helps overcome the
challenges faced by a traditional
database
initially we may start off by comparing
a single instance of a traditional
database on the cloud with a single
instance of cloud spanner
as our application grows and handles
more transactions
we naturally move the sharding to ensure
performance and spin up more database
instances
spanner on the other hand allows us to
easily horizontally scale out to achieve
our desired performance
and you only pay for what you need
fact Google's internal spanner instance
has been handling millions of queries
per second from many Google services for
years running various service backends
such as AdWords and Gmail
another important consideration as our
application scales is ensuring that it
is reliable and highly available
this requires creating yet more database
instances in different regions and
configuring them as replicas to create a
fallback
we also need to ensure that the data in
a primary instance is consistent with
the replicas
with Cloud spanner all this is a
one-click operation
spanner manages replication and provides
continuous availability while
maintaining strong consistency across
all the replicas with no effort from the
user
next let's consider security
data needs to be encrypted at rest and
often in transit as well to an order to
compliance requirements
this is quite challenging to set up
manually and requires considerable
development effort
however Cloud spanner provides both
encryption at rest as well as in transit
by default
finally when we consider the operational
efforts of maintaining this database
system that we have built for our
application
a traditional database would need
dedicated DBA teams for upgrading and
patching the software and the underlying
operating system and running maintenance
tasks to ensure Optimal Performance of
the database
since Cloud spanner is a managed
database
upgrades and maintenance of the database
are automatic and cause no downtime to
your application
now we can see the full picture of how
Cloud spanner enables us to
simultaneously achieve scale performance
and security all while keeping
operational efforts to a minimum
now that that we have a fair
understanding of what cloud spanner is
spanner is the right fit for you here
are the four scenarios where Cloud
spanner becomes the most applicable
firstly if you have a workload that uses
a nosql solution but needs transactional
consistency without compromising on
scale and availability you can leverage
Cloud spanners industry-leading external
consistency
secondly if your workload requires you
to shut your database for more read
write throughput or storage you can move
your data into a single spanner database
or instance to achieve the same results
at low cost and low operational overhead
without having to manage the
complexities associated with sharding
thirdly if your data needs to reside in
multiple regions and your application
requires strong consistency and high
availability you can configure Cloud
spanner in a multi-region configuration
to protect your database against
Regional failure
and lastly if you store your business
data in multiple database products with
variable maintenance overheads and
capabilities then you can consolidate in
a single spanner instance resulting in
significant cost savings and low
operational overhead
if you were able to check one or many of
these criterias then Cloud spanner is
the right choice for your workload in
fact you can get started with Cloud
spanner in production at as low as 40
dollars per month by combining both
granular instant sizing and cuds
now let's talk about how Cloud spanner
is priced when you use spanner you are
mainly charged for four components
firstly spanner keeps track of the
compute capacity which is measured in
processing units or nodes of an instance
over time you are charged for the number
of nodes or increments of 100 processing
units which is one tenth of a node
Spanish charges you for the average
amount of data in your spanner databases
including tables secondary indexes and
metadata over a one month period
spanner also charges you for the average
amount of storage used by your spanner
backups over a one month period
and lastly there are no bandwidth
charges for spanner replication or
network increase traffic however some
types of network egress traffic are
subject to bandwidth charges
Cloud spanner also offers a trial
instance to explore and become familiar
with it which is available at absolutely
no cost for up to 90 days
okay now you're convinced the cloud
spanner is the right solution for you
maybe your application uses a
traditional database today
how do you start using Cloud spanner to
scale
let's take a look at a simple repeatable
six step process to get started with
Cloud spanner
all migrations start with an assessment
where we understand the environment the
goals the risks and the opportunities
Mig wiser is a database migration
assessment tool that analyzes database
workloads and identifies challenges and
optimization opportunities
this helps to automate the assessment
process
we can now create a migration plan using
the information from the assessment
once the migration plan is in action the
first step is to modify the schema to be
compatible with spanner and optimize it
according to best practices
we need to carefully convert data types
and database objects from The Source
database engine to the destination
Harbor Bridge Is An Open Source
self-hosted tool that is recommended for
schema and data migrations for cloud
spanner
next update your application to use
cloud spanner
Google Cloud provides client libraries
in many popular languages to connect to
and interact with Cloud spanner
you may also need to translate some
queries in your application to Google
standard SQL which is based on ANSI SQL
you can also opt to use a new postgres
interface which allows you to write your
queries in the postgres dialect
the exact process of application
migration will be unique to your use
case
then migrate your data from The Source
database to Cloud spanner
again hubber bridge is the recommended
tool for low downtime data migrations to
spanner from supported Source database
systems
Harbor Bridge acts as an orchestration
tool between Google Cloud's data
services
it reads data using cloud data stream
stores incremental changes in cloud
storage and writes data to spanner using
cloud data flow
once your data is migrated validate that
the data and schema is consistent with
the source database
it can be challenging to validate
terabytes or petabytes of data manually
so you can automate this process with
data validation tool
it is a standardized data validation
method built by Google and supported by
the open source community that can
integrate into existing Google Cloud
products
it Compares structured or
semi-structured data from the source and
the target tables and verifies that they
match after the migration
once you have validated your data and
your application
you can cut over the production
application to point to the newly
migrated database
voila you are now ready to scale your
application with ease using Cloud
spanner
let's take a quick tour to the console
let's go ahead and create an instance
and database in Google Cloud spanner as
you can see that we are currently on
Google Cloud spanner page let's go ahead
and provision our first ever instance
let's click on create a provisioned
instance and you can see that the first
thing that we need here is instance name
the name of the instance must be unique
within your Google Cloud project
for the demo purposes let's call this
instance as test
the next thing that we need is instance
ID to permanently identify your instance
the instance ID must also be unique
within your Google Cloud project you
cannot change it later the instance ID
will be same as instance name unless you
want to go ahead and change it I am just
keeping it the same
next we choose the configuration an
instance configuration defines the
geographic placement and replication of
databases in that instance when you
create an instance you must configure it
either as a regional that is all the
resources are contained within a single
Cloud region or multi-region that is the
resources Span in more than one region
you make this Choice by selecting an
instance configuration which determines
where your data is going to be stored
for that instance
let me go ahead and show you how
multi-region configuration looks like
when I select multi-region it allows you
to choose multiple options where my
instance can span across multiple
regions in this case
however for the demo purposes I am going
to create a regional instance only in
U.S Central 1 region
you can see here that I also have an
option to compare configurations this
allows to compare pricing and
configuration between any of the two
regions that you might want to
lastly you have to specify the amount of
compute capacity for the instance the
compute capacity determines the amount
of serving and storage resources that
are available to databases in the
instance you specify the compute
capacity by choosing processing units or
nodes and then entering a quantity when
using processing units enter quantities
up to thousand in multiples of hundreds
like 100 200 300 and so on and enter
greater quantities in multiples of
thousands like thousand two thousand and
so on each node equals two thousand
processing units Cloud spanner can
handle millions of queries per second in
low latency
talking about storage for instance is
smaller than one node spanner allocates
409.6 GB of data for every 100
processing units in the database
while for instance of one node and
larger spanner allocates 4 TB of data
for each node for the demo let's go
ahead and input three nodes in this case
which means 3000 processing units which
in turn would allocate 12 TB of storage
let's go ahead and now create this
instance
as you can see our instance is now
created
let's go ahead and create a database
let me enter the database name
for the demo purposes let's call this
database as test DB
now let's choose the dialect to use for
this database you can opt between Google
standard SQL and postgres for Google
standard SQL dialect databases you can
optionally provide a set of ddl
statements that Define your schema
use the ddl templates to pre-fill common
elements if there are errors in the ddl
the Google Cloud console returns an
error when you try to create the
database
optionally select a customer managed
encryption key to use for this database
I'm just going to keep the default
selections and create the database
let's go ahead and click on create
option
[Music]
as you can see that the database is now
created on the right pane you can see
the permissions associated with this
particular database
now let's go ahead and create a table
inside this database
I am going to create a table singers by
running the following video
let's go ahead and submit this query
and you can see here the table singers
has been successfully created
now let's create an index for this table
let's run create index ddl here
and submit the query
in order to check the details associated
with this table one can click on show
details here as you can see in this case
here are the two details that we run
let's go ahead and add some dummy data
into the table singers as you can see
here here's the schema associated with
the table as we go into Data there's an
option to insert data this in turns
takes us to a query page here we can run
the insert query
now let me go ahead and run this query
to insert dummy data into my table
as you can see that the query runs
successfully an entry has been added to
my table singers in this case
let's go ahead and add another row into
our table singers
executing this query we see another row
has been inserted successfully now that
we have added some dummy data into our
table Singers Let's go ahead and display
it
I'm going to be running a simple select
star query in this case
select star from singers on executing
this query we can see that it displays
the two rows that we had inserted
earlier that being said you can also
view this data from the data tab easily
with this we have seen how easy and
straightforward it is to create a cloud
spanner instance we created database
stable inserted data into it and also
queried it using SQL language
in the beginning of the video we talked
about Cloud spanner being horizontally
scalable database let's see how let us
assume that you wish to scale in or out
your application for demo purposes I am
assuming that your application is not
getting as much traffic as earlier and
you wish to scale into one node to save
costs as we can see in this case that
your application is currently running on
three nodes let's go ahead and edit this
instance we are going to change the
number of nodes from 3 to 1.
let's go ahead and save this now
and voila you can see that the compute
capacity for cloud spanner has now
changed to one node
this is how fast and seamlessly Cloud
spanner can scale horizontally and with
that we have learned how to work with
Cloud spanner
let's now take a look at a real world
example of how Cloud spanner is helping
companies scale their business
sharechat is an india-based social
network company which serves over 160
million monthly active users who share
and view videos images gifs songs and
more in 15 different Indian languages
with demand Rising for local language
content and an increase in online
interactions in response to the covid-19
crisis
sharechat needed a more efficient way to
scale dynamically and allocate resources
as needed
when traffic unexpectedly grew by 500
percent over just a few days
sharechat were able to horizontally
scale with zero lines of code change by
migrating to Cloud spanner
moving over 120 tables with 17 indices
also help them to reduce their costs by
30 percent
Cloud spanner helps sharechat achieve
strong consistency across multiple
locations without having to rethink
their existing Data Systems
and with that we have come to the end of
today's video all in all we have covered
an overview of Google Cloud's Cloud
spanner and how it helps resolve the
challenges with traditional databases we
dived into to identify when Cloud
spanner is the right fit for you its
pricing model and how to migrate to
Cloud spanner lastly we saw a demo and
wrapped it with a customer case study
for all those of you who are Keen to
learn more about Cloud spanner please
refer to the links in the description
box to get additional resources
coming up in our next session we'll be
covering alloy DB
we'll start off with an introduction
discuss the advantages of alloy DB and
dive into its technical details
finally we'll see alloy DB in action
with a demo and a customer story
and that's a wrap don't forget to like
And subscribe to our YouTube channel and
click on the Bell icon to get notified
each time a new video is posted thank
you and stay tuned for our next video
[Music]